luigi di maio ministre italien des
affaires étrangères est à carthage pour
une visite de travail avec son homologue
othman jerandi l'occasion pour les deux
pays de parfaire les contours de leur
coopération notamment en matière de
gestion migratoire ce mardi matin dans
la capitale tunisienne plusieurs
associations se sont réunies pour
interpeller et rome sur les conditions
de détention des migrants tunisiens en
sicile le point tunis avec notre
correspondant bassim chéri
luigi di maio en visite officielle après
l annonce faite le 10 décembre dernier
par l'ambassadeur italien en tunisie
lorenzo 1 fanara à l'occasion pour les
deux pays de faire le point sur des
dossiers brûlants tels que la migration
la question libyenne le dossier des
déchets italiens ou encore le soutien de
rome auprès de l'union européenne dans
la sphère de la prolongation du gel des
fonds tunisiens en europe une visite
marathon pour le chef de la diplomatie
italienne dans un contexte de crise
migratoire entre les deux rives porte
d'entrée en europe l'italie est de plus
en plus pointés du doigt quant à sa
gestion et au traitement qu'elle réserve
aux migrants qui arrivent dans ces
centres de détention en marge de la
visite de luigi et di maio de nombreuses
associations de défense des droits
humains ont tenu ce matin au coeur de la
capitale une conférence de presse
objectif alerter les autorités et
l'opinion publique sur les circonstances
des décès de plusieurs jeunes tunisiens
dans ces centres italien le dernier en
date wissem abdellatif un jeune homme de
26 ans décédé dans des circonstances que
sa famille qualifient de douteuse à
l'hôpital centre camillo de rome après
son arrivée en sicile début octobre pour
ses proches qui attendent toujours le
rapatriement de sa dépouille les membres
d'avocats sans frontières les
circonstances ayant entraîné sa mort
restent à clarifier je vous propose
d'écouter à ce sujet zaineb rookie
membres d'avocats sans frontières on
veut saisir cette occasion pour
justement mettre en lumière la les
circonstances
douteuses de la mort de 800 actifs
mais aussi d'autres
d'autres d'autres tunisiens qui sont
morts dans des conditions assez opaque
pour le moment la vielle la mordovie cm
via un tout petit peu pour pour mettre
en lumière ces cds c'est là mais aussi
sur les circonstances de détention
administrative qui ont lieu dans les
centres de rétention en italie
et toutes ces conventions bilatérales
que la tunisie signe depuis des années
qui viennent un peu
apporté une discrimination envers les
tunisiens quant à leur rapatriement qui
vient un peu entravé leur droit d'asile
on essaie un peu de faire de collecter
des données par rapport par rapport aux
tunisiens qui sont rapatriés de d'italie
on essaye d'avoir des échanges avec eux
qui nous rapportent qu'ils n'ont aucun
aucune conscience de leurs droits ils
savent pas s'ils sont en mesure de
demander la protection internationale
dans quelles conditions un dossier qui
devrait être au coeur des discussions
entre les deux ministres des affaires
étrangères alors que le nombre de jeunes
tunisiens risquant leur vie pour
rejoindre les côtes européennes de
manière illégale est en constante
augmentation selon le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés les tunisiens ont
représenté en 2021 25 % des arrivées
illégale en italie sont onze mille
quarante deux personnes contre 20% en